aplausos de pie y emoción esta tarde en
la primera película en competencia nos
referimos al héroe del iraní asghar
farhadi el director es un conocido y muy
querido de lakua set y no decepcionó
esta vez con la historia de este hombre
que está en la cárcel por no haber
pagado una deuda y que durante un
permiso intenta convencer a su acreedor
de que logren un pacto para poder
recuperar su libertad sin embargo en ese
camino la redención parece imposible ya
que este sujeto se cruza con todos los
males de la sociedad en que vive la
usura la poca honestidad de las personas
e incluso la intromisión de las redes
sociales en la vida privada sin embargo
la película más esperada era la segunda
en competencia hoy nos referimos a titán
de la francesa julia du cono ella vino
hace cinco años a la semana de la
crítica y sorprendió con una película de
género voraz que tenía mucha sangre e
imágenes crudas esta vez regresa con
titan que ha sido calificada como una
película fantástica